hello everyone and welcome to this video
on requirement analysis for business
analyst as an aspiring business analyst
you must sometimes know what requirement
analysis is and what I would have to do
with that well you are not alone many
out there need help understanding
requirement analysis how it's done and
the actual need for such a step if you
want to understand the entire process of
requirement analysis and what value it
holds in the sdlc and the business
analysis process stay with us until the
end of this video Let's quickly
understand what business requirement
analysis is business requirement
analysis identifies understands and
documents the needs and requirements of
a system application or process it's a
critical step in the software
development life cycle and it's crucial
in business analysis as it is a vital
component of the requirement Gathering
process business analysts use
requirement analysis to clarify a system
or application functional and
non-functional requirements this
requirements can be collected from and
stakeholders stakeholders here can
include project sponsors domain experts
customers Etc this can be done through
interviews workshops and Survey among
other methods once business analysts
have gathered the requirements they can
analyze the requirements and determine
their priority feasibility and risk this
analysis ensure that the requirement are
clear specific and consistent with the
goals and objectives of this project the
need for requirement analysis in the
business analysis is to ensure that the
system or application being developed
meets the need and requirement of the
stakeholders and aligned with the
project goals and objectives with a
clear understanding of the requirements
business analysts can effectively
communicate them to the development team
and ensure that the final project meets
Expeditions and deliver value welcome to
the world of business analysis where
every successful project begins with a
detailed requirement analysis this
ensures a solid foundation for every
project no matter what domain today
every business analysis definitely
requires requirement analysis on
beforehand today we will look into the
essentials of requirement analysis and
learn how it ensures that the end
product aligns perfectly with the
business course and delivers value to
the organization or we get started if
these are the type of videos you would
like to watch then hit that subscribe
button and the bell icon to get notified
of our future content also don't forget
to like our videos
and if you are someone who is an
aspiring business analyst looking for
online training and graduating from the
West University or a professional who
Alex to switch careers with business
analytics by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply Love's
postgraduate program in business
analysis from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft the course link is in the
description box below and that link
should navigate you to the home page
where you can find the complete overview
of the program being offered so whether
you are an aspiring business analyst or
a seasoned professional looking to
enhance your skills please join us on
this journey as we unlock the power of
business analysis and pave the way for a
successful project outcomes that said
let's get started so firstly what
exactly is requirement analysis
requirements analysis is a crucial
aspect of the business analysis process
serving as the foundation for successful
project outcomes in this step-by-step
process us we will guide you through the
process of conducting requirement
analysis enabling you to uncover
stakeholder needs defined requirements
and ensure project alignment with
business objectives let's dive into
debate let's dive into the world of
requirement analysis in 10 simple steps
taking one step at a time first identify
stakeholders the first step in
requirement analysis is to identify the
stakeholders involved in the project
stakeholders are individuals or groups
with a vested interest in the project
and can influence its outcome conduct
stakeholder analysis to determine the
key stakeholders and understand their
roles responsibilities and expectations
next up is elect requirements once
stakeholders are identified the next
step is to elect their requirements this
involves gathering information about
their needs goals and constraints use
various techniques such as interviews
workshops surveys and observations to
engage stakeholders and extract relevant
requirements ensure open and effective
communication to Foster collaboration
and obtain a comprehensive understanding
of their expectations
third step is analyze requirements after
Gathering requirements analyzing and
making sense of the information
collected is crucial identify any
complex gaps or inconsistencies within
the requirements prioritize requirements
based on their importance and
feasibility use techniques such as
business process modeling data modeling
and prototyping to further refine and
validate the requirements
moving ahead we have the fourth
requirement which is documentation of
requirements cable documenting
requirements is essential to ensure
Clarity and Alignment among stakeholders
create a requirement document that
captures The Identical requirements in a
structured format include detailed
descriptions except its criteria and any
supporting documentation use visual aids
such as diagrams flowcharts and mockups
to enhance understanding and facilitate
communication
the fifth step is validate requirements
validation is a critical step to ensure
that the documented requirements
accurately reflect stakeholders and
expectations conduct reviews and
walkthroughs with stakeholders to
validate the requirements seek their
feedback and address any concerns or
discrepancies validation helps to
minimize the risk of misunderstandings
and reduces rework during the
development phase so far we have
discussed the five important steps
before we move ahead with the next five
steps let's hear from our Learners about
their success story after getting
graduated from Purdue University's
postgraduate program and business
analysis offered by simply learn in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft I have always been passionate
about any new things and improving my
teaching skills about five years ago I
realized that I have a gap in my
knowledge and to fill the Gap I need to
skill myself I chose simply learning at
my upskilling partner because of all
it's comprehensive curriculum and its
connection with Purdue University
my name is Carlos vinares
I live in Lexington in the city of
Kentucky in the United States I am an
assistant professor at Midway University
and I hold a PhD in management human
resources and Leadership I decided to
opt for the post graduation program in
business analysis from Superior which
has helped me a lot my professional and
personal life
I have been teaching having before I
moved to the United States years ago
I try to use Excel while teaching
research classes
but
since I only had the basic knowledge
about it and other business intelligence
tools it was very difficult for me at
the beginning but after completing this
class and learning how to use tools like
Excel Tableau power bi power query
problem I feel like it has been a total
game changer for me now I apply these
skills everywhere
which has also helped me a lot in my
yearly review I submitted all my
certificates to my university and based
on that my University plans to develop a
class focus on business analysis
starting in fall 2023.
and I am really excited
when I finally decide to go for an
online program I research a lot
and finally I chose synpreneur and I
must say it has been a wonderful
experience
you see how the business work is
changing now and Skilling yourself is
quite essential to keep up with the
change everything works on numbers now
data is more valuable and important than
ever so
I encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing now let's proceed with
sixth step managing requirements
requirements are Dynamic and subject to
change throughout the Project Life Cycle
establish a robust requirements
management process to handle changes
effectively Implement Change Control
mechanisms to access the impact of
requirement changes and ensure that they
are properly documented communicated and
approved regularly review the update and
requirements as the project progresses
the seventh step is communicate your
requirements
effective communication of requirements
is crucial for project success develop a
communication plan that outlines how
requirements will be shared with various
stakeholders use clear and concise
language to articulate the requirements
avoiding any ambiguity or jargon
leverage visual aids presentations and
interactive sessions to enhance
understanding and promote stakeholder
buy-in the eighth step is Trace
requirements requirements traceability
ensures that there is a clear link
between business objectives stakeholder
needs and the final solution establish
traceability mechanisms to track and
manage the dependencies between
requirements and other project artifacts
such as design documents test cases and
deliverables this helps maintain the
integrity and alignment of the
requirement throughout the process life
cycle now moving ahead we have the ninth
step prioritize your requirements not
all requirements are of equal importance
prioritize requirements based on their
value urgency and feasibility use
techniques such as Moscow that is
must-have should have could have and
won't have prioritization or can a model
to categorize the requirements based on
their impact on project success and
stakeholder satisfaction this enables
efficient resource allocation and
ensures that the most critical
requirements are addressed first
and lastly validate and verify the
solution once the solution is developed
it is essential to validate and verify
it against the documented requirements
so with that we have come to an end of
this session on requirements analysis
with business analysis tutorial
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all the queries at the earliest
until next time thank you for watching
stay safe keep learning and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here